le 23 décembre donc c'est là où il ya eu
le coup il ya eu le drame
donc oui là il a assassiné ma soeur
devancé devant ses enfants quoi quand
elle l'a connue elle avait 15 ans il en
avait 30
vous vous sentez protéger parce que il
est plus âgé que vous et finalement ça
deviendra votre meurtrier à la better
quoi qu'il arrive je pense quelque chose
et l'assistance sociale lui répond pour
ça restera toujours le père de vos
enfants
moi j'ai déjà assisté à des disputes où
il l'a déjà empoigné par le bras disait
que ouais qu'il préférait la voir morte
que tu avec quelqu'un d'autre
j'ai aussi un mémo vocal ma soeur une
façon un homme qui tape une fois est
après tout le temps lui a mis des coups
de couteau il là il l'a étranglée et il
lui a mis aussi des coups de poing et
voilà la forêt de 22 m
c'est là où le corps de ma fille a été a
été retrouvé elle a été transportée dans
une malle et enterré enterré dans cette
forêt là
c'est ici qu'il a mis la malle
[Musique]
cette haine fille très très très joyeuse
qui avait toujours le sourire qui était
hyper énergique quoi c'était on peut
dire une pile électrique elle tenait pas
en place quoi on appelait la sirène
parce qu'elle avait des longs cheveux
blonds et l'enfance c'était compliqué
parce que je pense qu'elle n'a pas aussi
supporté la séparation de mes parents
parfois elle partait on ne savait pas où
elle est et il faisait beaucoup de fugue
voilà quoi c'était un peu c'était un peu
compliqué quoi et puis après on l a
débarqué avec avec lui quoi ma soeur
elle a rencontré cet individu je puis
dire quand elle avait 15 ans il avait 33
ans et moi et ma mère déjà on n'était
pas du tout d'accord quoi puis voilà on
a dit qu'on irait à la police de le dire
que par rapport à la différence d'âge et
tous mais le lendemain quand on s'est
réveillé à l'été plus la cua est devenue
maman très vite à 16 ans après qu'elle a
eu déjà sa première fille déjà il ya eu
des déjà des violences jeudi écologique
quoi enfin réalité unités déjà insultant
méchant quoi avec ses propos quoi des
qui s'énerve et s'énerver vite quoi ils
avaient déjà commencé à la tap et alors
il dit tu peux pas accepter malgré tout
les excuses du monde ce qui fait quoi et
voilà à chaque fois ben il lui
promettait monts et merveilles devait
changer quelques temps et puis après ben
et il arrivait du deuxième et puis après
voilà quoi c'était comme ça quoi
c'est une maman
toujours avec le sourire rayonnante
toujours là pour ses enfants ses enfants
c'était sa vie quoi il passé à votre mon
corps bonjour ça va tu va bien ça va et
toi ça marche on sait jamais ça peut
toujours nous arriver aussi en ça arrive
à n'importe qui mais n'est pas à l'abri
je pense que tout le monde savait
qu'elle avait des soucis mais d'abord et
arriver à un drame comme ça je pense pas
avec mon ex mari j'ai vécu aussi des
choses où ce même mois le jour
d'aujourd'hui j'ai peur qu'il m'arrive
un jour dans cette situation là et moi
gérer directement porté plainte à la
police mais parfois la folie site sympa
tout en considération les plaintes et
les mains courantes quand il ya la peur
quand on est con et femmes soumises que
parce que moi j'étais femme soumise
pendant neuf ans c'est compliqué
n'est-ce pas d'aller voir l'assistante
sociale de demander de l'aide
des fois je les croisais le marché
justement aussi avec ses enfants a été
toujours avec ses enfants et elle est
toujours le bien-être des enfants
en fait lui marché avec les enfants et
elle l était derrière en fait elle
marche puisque lui marchaient plus vite
cannes avec les enfants et elle a marché
derrière lui comme à caen mais le court
et quand il n'hésita pense pas je te
tape
[Musique]
lui lui travaille pas il travaille pas
ma soeur non c'était toujours une fille
ambitieuse malgré qu'elle avait ses
enfants elle a travaillé aussi un peu de
ménage un peu d'entretien enfin des
choses comme ça et puis après il a voulu
aussi faire une formation
elle voulait se perfectionner aussi dans
l'es6 l'aller mais beaucoup l'esthétique
elle avait commencé à le faire après ne
pouvait pas terminée parce que lui
chaque fois ils empêchaient l'empêcher
tout le temps d'avancer quoi je pense
que c'est ça aussi au fur et à mesure qu
il énervé c'est qu'elle a commencé à
grandir elle a commencé à voir les
choses autrement et elle a compris
qu'elle voulait quelqu'un qui travaille
qui soit là pour ses enfants quoi
[Musique]
je sais que plusieurs fois à l'aller au
poste de police encore dernièrement
avant le 23 décembre
je sais aussi par le tir ceux d'une
personne qu'elle est là lui aussi chez
l'assistante sociale
déjà l'année dernière et ben voilà la
seule chose que en fait à lui aurait
répondu c'est c'est quand même le père
de vos enfants quoi il ya deux ans de ça
en fait elle avait eu un coup à l'oeil
on voyait plus on aille en fait c'était
un oeil
c'est comme si elle était aveugle d'un
oeil
il se gênait pas pour lui parler mal
devant tout le monde
même devant ses copines et bah il avait
dit en fait peut-être une semaine avant
comme ça un jour il va lui arriver
quelque chose si c'est pas moi ça sera
quelqu'un d'autre il faudra pas venir
faudra pas en vouloir
de toute façon il supportait pas que ma
fille déjà là il avait quitté et qu'elle
voulait même pas fêter mais le 24 avec
lui en famille quoi la veille de noël
quoi quand elle l'a connue elle avait 15
ans il en avait 30
vous vous sentez protéger parce que il
est plus âgé que vous et finalement ça
deviendra votre meurtrier où il avait
déjà frappé oui c'était vraiment violent
mais
je me suis dit oui peut-être il ira pas
jusqu au bout quoi voilà mais vu tout ce
qu'il a dit et puis j'ai vu le
comportement qu'il avait ça laissait à
entendre quoi là aussi un mémo vocal
aussi de ma soeur
le 21 octobre
je te jure
l'allemand je le dis je laime plus du
tout je suis pas là que je suis heureuse
quand il est là sera pas du tout limité
du forcing
je veux juste être avec les enfants je
serai à buzet voilà c'est là où elle
habitait là juste là bas derrière
ici-bas là il ya toujours acheter sont
pas ces cigarettes enfin et puis bah ici
c'est l'école en fait où c'est l'école
en fait on va l'emmener ses emplois le
message que j'ai à passer c'est alors
quoi en fait on aime quelqu'un et elle
ne veut plus alors là dessus quelque
part maintenant la wave et qu'elle
repose en paix elle est soulagée parce
qu'il y avait non seulement la violence
physique
et la violence psychologique on sait
tous ce recueil ici avec des voisins
avec des amis avec la famille proche
voilà ce qu'on peut lire nokia ces mines
repose en paix mon ange on t'oubliera
jamais
e
[Musique]